[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
My name is Daniella
Smalls-Perkins.
And my name is Dorris Scott.
And we are the co-founders
of Mi-R community.
Today, during this
lighting talk,
we're going to reflect a
little bit on Mi-R community
this past year and also invite
you to join some of the efforts
that we plan to carry
out in the next year.
I'll first start with the hope
for Mi-R. So the hope for Mi-R
is to promote the visibility
and leadership of R users
from marginalized races,
genders, the LGBTQ community,
and the disabled community
through community
led efforts that support
professional development.
Right now, we have slightly
under 200 members and allies
within our community slack
from different countries,
backgrounds, experiences,
and all flavors
of data people, data scientists,
data analysts, et cetera.
All of these folks
are willing to share
their unique perspectives
and their love of R.
Some of the highlights
from this past year really,
first, of course, is
just getting the group
off the ground and starting
to see people roll in.
We started right as the
pandemic hit the entire world
and tried to garner support
and momentum just as the US
was going through a
racial reckoning-- excuse
me, a reckoning
for racial justice.
So to see the
outpouring of support,
Allison Horst designed
logo and graphics for us
to see other members join
and support each other
and lead new initiatives.
That's just been truly special.
Another huge highlight
of this past year
were the webinars
held by our community members.
Darren Ramsland led
a webinar focused
on some of the new features
in the recently updated dplyr
and then some of his
favorite functions
associated with that library.
Also, Shel Kariuki, provided
a webinar focused on ggplot2
and shared some of
her tips and tricks
when doing data visualization.
We also had an RStudio
instructor certification panel
led by Greg Wilson, Shel
Kariuki, Yanina Bellini
Saibene, in which they
talked about the process
to become an RStudio
certified instructor.
And we've also been having
some study sessions every month
for those that are
preparing to take the exam
to become an RStudio
certified instructor.
So those are some of
the top highlights.
I'll now pass it
to Dorris to share
a couple more reflections.
I have a lot of reflections
on how our first year went
as an organization.
But for the sake of time, I will
just share only one reflection.
We originally created
Mi-R because we
wanted to create a space
in which people who did not
see themselves in the
data science community
could come together.
We hope that Mi-R would
extend past our ability
to adequately support all of the
intersectional backgrounds that
are in the community.
And indeed, it has.
We are so grateful for
members of our community
who provide their unique
perspectives, insights,
knowledge, and skills.
Thank you so much for all that
you bring to our community.
In 2021, we are working
on several endeavors.
We don't want to give
away our full lineup.
So here's a preview
of what's to come.
We are currently
working on endeavors
to ensure that Mi-R webinars
are accessible to Mi-R members
with disabilities along with
the wider community of R users
with disabilities.
And we are working
on a Tidy Tuesday
event in which we will
focus on best practices
to make R visualizations
more accessible.
In addition, we intend to have
more professional development
workshops such as resume
workshops and interview
preparedness, along
with a digital security
webinar for researchers sharing
their work with the public.
So if you identify as an
underrepresented R user,
then we invite you to join
Mi-R community as a member.
And if you'd like to
support the community
but don't necessarily identify
as an underrepresented R user,
then we would love to
have you join as an ally
in support of the members.
You can find us on Twitter
and YouTube @mircommunity.
And you can also visit us
at www.mircommuntiy.com.
Thanks so much for
listening to our talk.
DORRIS SCOTT: Thank you.